hello there reject nation greg and john
here today we're gonna watch the
thor loving thunder clip that apparently
came out moved to a new place just
finished setting up the background clear
out a bunch of stuff got that shaggy rug
oh yeah super shaggy rugs shagadelic
baby yeah you should have heard this
room before this rug and some other
stuff was on here incredibly echoey so
if you want to complain about the audio
go right ahead we're working on it yeah
it's always a work in progress
always room to improve never going to
get that audio down no matter how far we
come into youtube we're just never going
to use it perfect this audio setup is
the day we will move again guys let's
see this clip it's only like 20 seconds
longer
[Music]
here
you're
boy
damn that was that was building up to
something cool i'm still not sure if
that's the first scene where thor sees
jane you know because that damn trailer
makes you when he goes like jane the way
they cut that treadmill that's the first
time but then i don't know there's just
something about this moment in
particular i don't know what to make of
it i don't know what to make of it part
of it makes me wonder if we'll follow
jane through a couple different
multiversal experiences seeing different
thors or something on her way to our
thor that would kind of be a surprising
way to go i feel so sorry for thor he
treats
like how he's caught her
like a puppy
i know
he's your boy
you're back oh i'm so overjoyed to see
you you look like upset at jade yeah
look at you ripped me away from my buddy
boone companion of so many years broke
apart now is back let us have our
reunion moment it comes down just a few
weeks waited forever for this trailer
and then the movie's just suddenly
coming out yeah isn't that crazy no
anticipation cycle
it'll be here before you know it
well i imagine we'll get more clips down
the road but guys what did you think
about this moment uh so short i feel
like there's still not enough to gestate
from it you know yeah wait give us more
marvel or somebody happy hack tap into
the mainframe at least half the movie
before it comes out
upset everyone in doing so cause a
massive backlash mess up everyone's
ability to watch the movie it's just one
whole piece stick around there's more
videos come this week
you